and jay-z and I didn't need little Bruce
Springsteen and all of these they got
all these people that was President
Trump mic and celebrity endorsements
like when Bruce Springsteen backed
Hillary Clinton in 2016 now the boss is
hidden back with this dig at Trump
we're living in a frightening time the
stewardship of the nation is it's been
thrown away to somebody who doesn't have
a clue as to what that means and
unfortunately have somebody who I feel
doesn't have a grasp of the deep meaning
of what it means to be an American Greg
you were in the celebrity world with I'm
a celebrity do they actually believe
you're Lawrence I'm a world-class
celebrity and I'm a little insulted that
you didn't say that right let's start no
but here's the thing it's hard for Bruce
Springsteen because his persona is a
blue-collar man of the people and Trump
is actually a bonafide populist folk
hero and it's like there's a lot of
overlap between Springsteen's audience
and throw Trumper x' and it's driving
them crazy and it does bug them that
their popularity is being marginalized
by Trump if you're as popular as
Springsteen or anybody you're wondering
why it doesn't that counter the rise of
your this noxious enemy it's not and
that kind of just bothers if it's like
what am I chopped liver
no the cultural delicatessen you are not
isn't it that President Trump talks
their language though like he's this
rich guy but he speaks in very small
sound bites can I just take it the other
side you know Bruce Springsteen it was
my neighbor in New Jersey our kids went
to school together
we were there or living there 9/11 our
community was the most stricken
community per capita in the world and he
what he he did to help that community
was really amazing and he's right about
the I think the right generally
Republicans and President Trump losing
sight of something very crucially
American and and I think when the
president said he was gonna ban all
Muslim immigrants when he separated
immigrant families at the border those
things were fundamentally and I agree
absolutely Bruce Springsteen they were
American and I I think that that's what
Bruce would speak into and adults are
not related to I don't get that what no
I mean it people if you have a problem
with children traveling with people
they're not related to you have to do
some separation if you don't like the
process I mean I don't make it I'm just
ease with to I think black marks on the
Trump presidency that history will come
to regard and Bruce Springsteen right to
point them out let's get you in on the a
lot of people don't care about his
personality they care about what he
delivers on right yeah that's actually
true and you know the president very
well and I would say that he's not
perfect no he's not perfect and I take
issue with that trio different from
Jesse perfect right now he's cold he's
crafting a sculpture of the president's
race it's beautiful it's I enjoy Lionel
Richie's hello he's doing what surveys
the president does a lot of things and
says a lot of things that I don't agree
with and I don't like and that I think
are beneath the presidency but I
wouldn't say that he doesn't understand
America or that he's not an American
because he really does embody the
American dream you know here is someone
who did what he loved for a long time
did very well at it and now he's
President of the United States against
all odds and whenever he goes out to
these rallies I think one of the reasons
they're so well attended is because he
talks directly to people about his dream
and about his aspirations and that
resonates and and for people who
demonize him like Bruce Springsteen who
were so polemic and so ready to call him
a [ __ ] you should operate with a little
bit more curiosity why you should go for
the short money sometimes right I've
been at all of these rallies and these
people are average day people they love
the president I think that for
entertainers they could make a choice
right I am I admire the people who
decide not to in Nashville in country
music for the most part you could
imagine that they've got a wide variety
wide audience right a lot of diverse
audience and they want to keep it they
almost never talk about politics they
are there to lift and entertain that's
what they do all right we're the fastest
seven is coming up right next on five